I am pretty sure I have the best mom in
the entire world up.
Have somebody ready to debate already. Okay.
I know that's subjective. I get that.
I hope you do feel the same way about your mom.
I I, I also want to acknowledge that not everybody does.
And so know that we feel that, sorry
for your experience, if that's yours.
But I, I've been blessed.
It's the grace of God in my life
to have the mom that I have.
I'm not just saying that 'cause I forgot
to get her a card today on Mother's Day,
but, um, I, I genuinely mean that.
I I do Many of you know our story.
Uh, my family has experienced a lot.
My parents got divorced when I was a freshman in high
school, and my sisters had two strokes in the last 15 years.
And so my mom is a warrior
and she has prayed for decades
and carried in many ways our family
and has cared for us in real,
real deep ways.
And so just wanna praise God for that.
And, uh, I've said this
before, I know that I am not who I am today without my mom.
And so just want to acknowledge that.
But as I say that, even preparing to say that, uh,
that it brings up a bit of a tension in me
because I know at the same time that there is a,
a measure of me not loving her well in return,
in response to her great love for me.
I didn't take it. Uh, I, I took it for granted.
And uh, I've sought to be better.
But historically I just have not
done a great job making sure that she feels loved,
like the ways that she loved me
and cared for, like, uh, she cared for me in those ways.
Always a great way to start a sermon
with a controversial statement and a confession.
So, uh, why do I tell you that?
Well, even more important than the way that we love our moms
is what we're gonna talk about today.
A genuine love for God
and for others in response to God's great love for us.
This realigned series we're talking about
has been showing us the perfect standard of Christ,
how he's been pulling us toward the perfect standard
of vertical that he set.
That's what we're doing all summer.
But, but this piece today is so important.
I think we're talking about genuine love.
I think this one is so important to, because,
because most of us in the room today
just assume we are loving.
If I would ask you, you'd say, of course I am.
Well, often what we will do is we'll try to set the standard
of vertical, this love standard ourselves
from the bottom up and,
and we'll conform to others
leading us to think that, that this standard,
what we've set in the world
or what others would say, this is vertical.
And so we are not that far off from it
if we're going according to this standard or that standard.
But, but again, when we set the vertical from above of
when we let Jesus's life be the standard,
when when we look at his love, then we realize
how far off we actually are from that.
And so what I wanna show you today is how,
what we're studying in this whole chapter
of Romans chapter 12, how, how all of it
is really just an extended display of
what love looks like in a transformed life.
Like if you've been changed by Jesus,
this whole chapter is what love looks like for you,
really, how, how God's love for us
changes us so much
that we love God completely differently because of it.
That that it changes us, that we love others in the church
so differently, that we also even love
our enemies very differently.
And where does that come from?
Romans five verse eight says, God shows his love
for us in that while we were still sinners,
enemies, Christ died for us.
So God, that's your standard.
This is not complicated here today,
but it is impossible for us
to do apart from your love for us.
And so, God, I pray you'd open our hearts today,
open our lives that we would be willing, ready to hear
and receive and act on in love for you, what you've shown us
and given us in Christ.
This is your word. Do your work through it, God,
in Jesus' name, amen.
So turn with me back now to Romans 12,
this chapter, we're gonna work
through all summer, Romans 12.
What I want you to look at
as we get there is just the first
couple words of verse nine.
So Romans chapter 12, big number 12,
little number nine under that.
And it's gonna be on your notes as well. It's really simple.
Just four words today.
That's all we're gonna study, but it'll be so rich.
Romans 12 verse nine,
first four words say this, let love
be genuine.
Let love be genuine.
That word genuine brings with it the idea
of not having hypocrisy, that you're not putting on a front.
It's not fake, it's real.
I love how verse nine reads in the new living translation.
It says, don't just pretend to love others.
Really love them. A lot of pretending in the world.
That's not what we're talking about.
We're talking about genuine real love.
And I think that's the thread that runs
through the entire chapter of Romans 12.
I'm gonna argue that the whole thing is really about love.
It says a lot of different words,
but it's all about how you truly love God.
How you truly love your brothers and sisters in the church,
and how you truly love your enemies.
That's what it's all about.
But here again, we can't start there.
Like I can't just say to you,
all right, let's go love each other.
Let's go love the Lord. Let's go love the enemies.
We can't just go with that
because what that turns into then is a moralistic message
that just beats us up and tells us how far we are from God
because we can't do it very well.
And you're discouraged walking out of here
or tomorrow at least instead of encouraged.
That's why the foundation we set today is so critical.
The foundation we must start with is
that God first loved us, not
how we should be loving.
How did God love us? First?
He first loved us, which is how first John four,
verse 10 puts it, the foundation of our love.
Watch this in. This is love.
Not that we've loved God, but that he loved us
and sent his son to be the propitiation for our sins.
See that this, this is what love looks like.
That's what it says, right? This is love.
Not your love for him.
The love is, is not some bottom up standard that we set.
The world says this is how love looks like.
This is what you should do if you love someone.
No, it's not measured also by how we love God.
It's not any of that.
Love is exemplified by the fact that God loved us first
and not just in a sentimental feelings based kind of way.
It wasn't any of that He loved in an active
sacrificial kind of way.
God, the Father sent God the Son to be the offering
for our sin to be the sacrifice that would fully atone
for his people's sin.
That is love. We deserve his wrath.
We deserve his anger as his enemies.
Yet, because God is love, he did what he did.
He offered his son to pay the penalty for our sin.
That's love that. That is sacrificial.
That's the standard. That is the vertical standard of love.
There is no other way we can define love
as the world might try.
There's no other way. This is love.
That is our life's foundation. Okay, so great, we agree.
What do we do with that? What does
that do for us?
Then what do we do with it?
Romans 12, Right?
Romans one through 11 is this long
explanation of that of love.
God's love for us, his salvation of us.
That's how he did it. Remember what verse one started
with in Romans 12?
Go back to it. I appeal to you therefore
because of what he did, because of God's love.
Therefore, I appeal to you brothers, by the mercies of God,
the love of God to present your bodies
as a living sacrifice, holy
and acceptable to God, which is your spiritual worship.
Do not be conformed to this world,
but be transformed by the renewal of your mind, that
by testing you may discern what is the will of God.
What is good and acceptable and perfect.
So we talked about a couple weeks ago, right, that,
that this is the idea that
because of God's abundant mercies,
because he's made you dead to sin
because he's made you alive to God in Christ
because he's done all of that.
Worship Him, right? Worship, that's what it says.
Open your hands of your life.
Get off the throne of your own heart.
Let Jesus reign on the throne of your heart, say to God,
God, you've given me everything.
So I'm gonna give you everything that's worship.
It's not just singing, it's not just giving.
It's not just serving. It is all of me.
God, I'm all for you.
I'm dying to myself to give you myself.
And he's gonna realign your mind.
He's gonna realign your will to obey his will.
That's what he does in it.
And so what we're saying in essence is that in response
to God's love for us, we are then
to love our God wholeheartedly.
Right? That's what verses one
and two say, basically in response to God's love,
the foundation of his love, what do we do?
We love him wholeheartedly.
And like verse nine says, genuinely, we're not acting.
It's without hypocrisy.
We love God genuinely with all that we are.
But what does that actually mean? Uh,
of course I'm writing this all week and thinking about these
and so I'm, I'm asking questions
that I think you're, I'm asking.
And so when we say it all the time, love God with all
that we are, do we really actually know what that means?
Like I wanna be careful there. I wanna be clear.
Do we really love God? How do we do that?
Well go back to the way God loved us. How did he prove it?
He didn't just say it though.
He certainly says that He loves us.
He didn't just say it right.
He sacrificed his son to say, I love you
to show us that He loves us.
It was active, it was tangible.
It was meeting a specific need that we had
and he knew he could provide for it.
You may have heard of a book called The Five Love Languages.
It's often used in marriage and counseling
and things like that.
I'm not all in on it, so just take it or leave it.
But, but I at least know that my wife is not a gifts person.
She is words of affirmation and physical touch.
And so if I go into Mother's Day,
just strictly thinking gifts, if I just go flowers, if I go
with, uh, presents
and all these things, if that's all the way, it's like I,
I think that's how she should be loved.
I'm gonna give her gifts and that I'm gonna miss it, right?
But be completely off base.
What I need to do is make sure that I tell her all the time
how much she means to me.
How great a mom she is, how great a wife she is.
I need to tell, I need to hold her hand. I need to hug her.
I need to be all present with her in those kinda ways.
That's what she needs. 'cause I know that's what's going
to meet her greatest need.
It's similar but much greater with God.
He knew that our greatest need was to be forgiven
of our sin, to be freed from the bondage of sin
and to be brought back into relationship with him.
And so what did he do? He sacrificed his
son to make it happen.
He didn't just give us a better life.
He didn't just make our lives comfortable
because that's not our greatest need.
Our greatest need was to be forgiven.
And so he paid the price to make that happen. That's love.
And that is what should spark our love for him.
That is what should then turn our hearts towards
obedience for him.
Our willingness to give our lives for him
to do things his way, not our way.
To spend time with him, to cherish him, to worship him.
That when we remember his love for us is
what then sparks our love
for him again.
Jesus said, the most important commandment is for you
and I to love the Lord our God with all of our heart, soul,
and mind with everything we are.
That is the absolute most important thing we can do.
That's what life has to be all about.
As we talk about this though, I want to, I wanna be
giving you a couple cautions.
There are a couple traps we can fall into
when we're talking about this.
So I wanna share two traps.
One for all of us, but then one more specifically
for those in leadership.
But here's one trap that, that you might be,
I could easily fall into.
One trap is that when we talk about loving God with all
that we are, it's possible for you
to love God vicariously through
someone else to try to do that.
Whether that's me or whether that's an online influencer,
or whether that's some kind of a CG leader in your life
or, or, or whatever it is.
And, and what you're doing is you hope that
by coming in here or by watching that reel
or watching that sermon, that somehow their love
for God will rub off on you.
Like, man, I love going to that church
because those people love God so much,
those people, right?
And I just, I just love being around.
I kinda get caught in the wash.
I I get in the coattails of their love.
And, and you just hope that somehow it will rub off on you.
Listen, that's not how this works.
It's, it's not possible for me to love God for you and,
and grow your love for God by virtue of me.
Uh, it's, it just doesn't work that way.
You know, you can meet with this God too.
You have the same access.
It's not like a special class of Christians
that you're not a part of,
and you're not gonna be able to know God like they do.
It's possible you have the same Holy Spirit
and the same word of God,
and you can meet with him if you are a believer
just like I can.
And so that's a trap that you can fall into
and just say, I'm gonna ride on their momentum.
That's not what we need to be about.
But lemme give you the flip side.
Here's another trap that I
and other leaders could be falling into.
In fact, our leadership team on staff went to a retreat,
a conference this week, and this God wrecked me on this one.
Uh, So I've been dealing with this all week.
But, but here's, here's the temptation for me
or even for you.
I, I am tempted to go through the motions
of loving God merely for you instead of
for intimacy with God myself.
Meaning I know I have to come on Sunday
with something ready to go.
I know that I have to act a certain way.
I have to know the Bible enough.
I have, I have to do all these things in my position so
that you don't think I'm unqualified.
Like I have to be able to like,
and so there's temptations that come up
where I know I have to be ready.
And all I'm doing it for at times is for
the ungenuine way to present myself to you.
It's the exact opposite of verse nine. Let love be genuine.
Mine is that, that that can be hip hypocrisy, right?
It's loving God merely so that you think I do.
And that's so wicked, isn't it?
How, how immature do we get when those things, like,
I'm just hoping that they love God enough that I can kind
of ride in on them with no, like, how immature are we here?
Like this is where we're at.
You see how far off we can get from this?
Like, like we're setting some standard this way.
That's totally off.
So there should be a measure of
conviction here for some of us.
And I, I say that,
but I also wanna give some encouragement
as I'm processing this myself all week.
There's also a measure of encouragement hopefully here.
If that's you and you're kinda like hoping everybody else
loves God enough and you kind of come with them,
or if you're faking it somehow, listen, that means
there's more on the table for us with God, right?
If we're just kind of half baked going through this thing,
if we're just sort of, kind of skating through
with everybody else and we're faking like we are, there's,
there's an opportunity here for us, each one of us,
to grow deeper, to have more experiential passion
with the Lord than we do.
Like why, why do we settle?
Why do we settle for this sort of surface level churchianity
that we're kind of decent people
and we show up at church whenever it's convenient?
Like why do we settle for that instead of knowing, getting
to know this God who's loved us like he does?
Why do we settle for something less than what he's offering
to every one of us?
And now I realize there are all kinds
of reasons we might feel distant from God
and feel like we kind of have to fake it or whatever it is.
Maybe it's hurt you've felt or doubt or,
or maybe it's the distractions of your phone
and all the things on tv, whatever it is.
Maybe it's even fatigue.
You're just burned out tired
and there's, there's a distance you feel from God.
What do you do with that? And you're like, I,
I wanna love God, but I don't feel like anything right now.
What do you do? You run home to your father,
like you run home to your father who is waiting,
who's got his arms open, he's got the goat prepared.
He's, he's ready. You, you gotta run home like you,
you gotta get rid of distractions.
You gotta refocus. You need to remember the gospel.
Remember who God says you are.
You're not that, you're not
your past, you're not the distraction.
You remember who he says you are.
And that breaks through the walls.
You remember his love breaks through the walls
reprioritizing him.
Have you ever, you ever seen one of those news clips
of someone who was saved from like
a burning car or rubble
or something that, that somebody like a first responder
saved their life Or maybe it was a cardiac arrest
or something and, and the, the person saved their life.
Have you ever seen the video of them meeting
that person a couple months later?
Like, you saved my life. How do they handle that?
Do they go in it like, yeah man, hey, great to meet you.
Good to see you, thanks and move on.
Complete transformation, right? But you've saved my life.
Thank you for pulling me outta that.
I think they're overwhelmed. Can't even hold it together.
Overwhelmed with gratitude.
How much more should we be with the God of the universe
who has saved us eternally
from separation from him forever?
He saved us from that.
Not because we deserved it, but
because he just chose to reach into it
and say, you're mine by grace.
And so again, loving God with all that we are,
that's first priority.
But that's not all that Romans 12 shares about love.
That's just the first two verses.
Listen next to verses three through 13.
For by the grace given to me, I say to everyone
among you not to think
of himself more highly than he ought to think.
But to think with sober judgment, each according
to the measure of faith that God has assigned for,
as in one body, we have many members.
The members do not hold the same function.
So we though many are one body in Christ individually
members, one of another, having gifts that differ according
to the grace given to us.
Let us use them if prophecy proportion of our faith,
if service in our serving, if the one
who teaches in his teaching, the one
who exhorts in his exhortation, the one
who contributes in generosity, the one who leads with zeal,
the one who does acts of mercy with cheerfulness,
let love be genuine.
A w***e, hate what is evil. Hold fast to what is good.
Love one another with brotherly affection.
Outdo one another in showing honor.
Do not be slothful in zeal. Be fervent in spirit.
Serve the Lord. Rejoice in hope. Be patient in tribulation.
Be constant in prayer.
Contribute to the needs of the saints
and seek to show hospitality.
Now, we studied part of that last week when we talked
about serving of course.
But verses nine through 13 add a lot
of color to that, don't they?
We're gonna look at each of these facets over the next
couple months a lot more deeply just piece by piece.
But for now, did you see something about this section?
Did you see how others centered?
It was, it was giving your life away.
For others, it was having a deep affection.
For others, it was praying for others,
it was giving to others.
But notice a distinct orientation in this part.
All of that is directed toward the church.
It's all toward the church.
Your gifts used for the church and your lifestyle.
For verse 13, the saints, the church.
There's dozens of similar words in the New Testament.
We call them the one anothers.
Just do a study in your Bible app.
Sometime search one another
and just see the dozens of times Paul commands the church
to do things to one another, like serve one another, care
for one another, speak truth to one another.
All of those things, there's dozens of them here,
love one another.
So again, here's the point. You
and I are to love our brothers
and sisters in the church sacrificially.
When we look at this section three through 13, in response
to God's love for us,
like Christ has loved us.
We are to love our brothers and sisters within the church.
Listen, if you're gonna obey these kind
of commands, can't be selfish.
It can't be about you. It's all about serving others.
It's you're like, okay, great. What does that look like?
Very specific ways here in these verses, right?
How do I love the church better? Look at these verses.
What does he say? If you're gonna compete at something even
more than church softball leagues compete at being the most
honoring to others, outdo each other in it.
Like if we walked around just out trying
to out honor each other, how great would that be?
You'd wanna be there. You'd wanna be a part of that, right?
He also said, don't come in here just as a consumer.
Look for ways to serve your brothers and sisters.
Pray for one another. Like when was the last time you prayed
by name for a fellow Christian
that they would be supported,
encouraged, healed, whatever it is.
When was the last time you prayed for them by name?
He says, pray for one another. That's one way you love.
The church says, we're also
to give financially to support others.
Now, that means of course, directly,
but are you giving anything Like
so brother and sister has a need?
You say, Hey, here's, here's money.
Here's a resource, here's a something
that I can help you with.
Are you giving financially through the church?
Because not only do we keep lights on
and do ministry, those kind of things, benevolence,
there's members of need you don't even know about.
You can give to this fund that we use to provide.
There's disaster relief.
That part of what you give goes to support
towns ravaged by tornadoes.
Brothers and sisters in need.
There we can give to brothers and sisters in need.
But that's again the realignment process.
Jesus came not to be served but to serve. Remember that.
And so the more we pursue him, the more we will all look
for ways to love
and serve other people we'll clamor for it.
We'll look for it and search for ways to love that.
That's just gonna be part of who we are to love others.
Well, and here's why this is so important.
I know it seems like we're harping on it a lot, but,
but this is why it's so critical.
Jesus said, John 1335, by this,
all people will know that you are my disciples.
If you have love for one another, Like this is missional,
this is, this is reputation in the world.
What are they seeing from us?
Do they even know we're Christians?
How are we gonna, how are they gonna know
how we love one another?
That means we don't just have similar affinities.
That means we don't just have a general
affection for one another.
That means we don't just have a lack of conflict.
It means we are genuinely sacrificing
for one another.
That's love. How can you
better love the fellow members of the church in real ways?
You might have noticed though that Romans 12 continues.
There's still some left, right?
So again, the lens of love, God's love for us.
First, look now at verses 14 through 21.
Bless those who persecute you. Bless and do not curse them.
Rejoice with those who rejoice, weep with those who weep.
Live in harmony with one another.
Do not be haughty or prideful, but associate with the lowly.
Never be wise in your own sight. Repay no one evil for evil.
But give thought to do what is honorable in the sight
of all if possible.
So far as it depends on you live peaceably with all.
Beloved, never avenge yourselves,
but leave it to the wrath of God.
For it is written. Vengeance is mine.
I will repay, says the Lord.
To the contrary, if your enemy is hungry, feed him.
If he's thirsty, give him something to drink for.
By so doing, you'll heap burning coals on his head.
Do not be overcome by evil, but overcome evil with good.
Did you notice a shift of the orientation
of this passage, right?
Just before this, Paul was focused on
relationships within the church.
But here, right outta the gate, bless those
who persecute you.
Bless and do not curse them.
He's talking about relationships.
Now he's, he's widening the the lens of love,
to not just be people who you agree
with and who agree with you.
But now he's saying, Hey, look, this is bigger than that.
You love more those outside.
He's talking about unbelievers.
So again, we're gonna look at each one
of these points over the next couple months.
But the point here today is that
because of God's love for you, you are
to love your enemies radically.
That's his point here. You love God wholeheartedly.
You love your brothers and sisters within the church
sacrificially and you love your enemies radically, all
because of God's love for you.
I mean, just think about what Jesus said in Matthew five.
This is the most famous sermon in history.
But what Jesus was doing with it
was he was resetting the vertical standard, right?
The whole sermon is Jesus saying,
this is actually what I'm about.
This is what Christianity faith
following the Lord is all about.
Watch what he says here.
You've heard it was said, an eye for an eye, a tooth
for a tooth revenge.
But I say to you, do not resist the one who is evil.
But if anyone slaps you on the right cheek, turn to him.
The other. Also, if anyone would sue you
and take your tunic, your outside garment,
let him have your cloak as well.
If anyone forces you to go one mile, go with him two miles.
Give to the one who begs from you.
Do not refuse the one who would borrow from you.
You've heard that it was said, you shall love your neighbor
and hate your enemy.
But I say to you, love your enemies
and pray for those who persecute you so that you may be sons
of your father who is in heaven,
for he makes his sunrise on the evil,
on the good sends rain on the just and on the unjust.
Like, like. Doesn't that sound so radical to us?
Like in, in a world
that's focused on vengeance and selfish ambition
and taking of what's mine?
Jesus's words stand out like a lighthouse
in a very dark world.
Like he says things that sound so crazy.
But I'm really glad he gave us the reason he said it,
because he continued
and he said this, for, if you love those who love you,
what reward do you have?
Do not even the tax collectors do the same.
And if you greet only your brothers,
what more are you doing than others?
Do not even the gentiles do the
same, right?
What he's saying is this is the kinda love
that's gonna stand out.
It doesn't take anything different for you
to love somebody who loves you, right?
An unbeliever can do that.
Anybody in the world doesn't matter if, if you're loved,
you can love them back so easily.
It takes a whole lot of transformation though,
to love someone who hates you, Who hurts you.
That's what he's saying is there's a transformation I'm
doing in you that's enabling you
to love even your enemies.
Because remember, who initiated all this God did
by loving us as his enemies.
And so that's the question we have to wrestle with is like,
all right, what does that mean to, to love my enemies?
I, I know I'm supposed to. What does that even look like?
Because I don't have tunics and cloaks.
I'm not asking people to walk a mile.
Like what does, what does this look like today?
It's a different world. What do we do with that?
Just give you a couple examples.
This means that instead of cursing people that you disagree
with on social media, you instead bless them.
It means when your agnostic coworker gets a promotion over
you, you celebrate with them.
Or when your Hindu neighbor, his dad dies,
you grieve with him.
It means you walk humbly in the world,
not trying to position yourself with the most popular
or most wealthy people, but instead you are able
and willing to care for the least
of these in real hidden ways.
It means you live honorably with integrity
and you as best you can seek
to make your life match your words.
And when it doesn't match up, you own it
and you repent of it.
It means when you are hurt,
you let God take the vengeance, not you.
Which by the way, he's way better at,
way better at it than we are.
So why do we even try?
Let him do it in the right way as he sees fit?
I just love the last verse here in Romans 12 verse 21.
It says, do not be overcome by evil
but overcome evil with good.
Like what if we lived our lives like that?
What if we looked for every way to overcome evil?
Not by using snarky comments or boycotts,
but by doing good over and above what they've done
and just overwhelming the world with good instead
of the evil it experiences.
How much different would the world be if we did that?
How much different would we be if we live like that?
And so love God wholeheartedly.
Love the brothers and sisters sacrificially.
Love your enemies radically.
But we cannot forget church like I could. I could say that.
And we walk outta here, all kind of discouraged,
all kind of beat up a little bit.
'cause we know we don't do that very well.
So let's not forget where we began.
Remember, it's not about how much better you can love.
It's not about how much more you can love them.
Our foundation is God's great love
for us in Jesus's death and resurrection.
That's the standard. Even we were his enemies.
He loved us in that specific way so that we could know him.
That's what he did.
Don't forget that
before you ever loved God, he loved you first
before you could ever serve God.
He served you first before you could ever forgive
or love your enemy.
He forgave and love you as his enemy.
Don't forget that
because that's what then compels us to love God with all
of our hearts, to love our brothers
and sisters in sacrificial ways,
to love our enemies in radical ways
that stand out in the world.
That's what compels us. It's God's love for us.
You might have heard the name Frederick Douglass
before he was an author of course,
but he primarily was known for his tireless efforts
to abolish the slave trade in
America in the late 18 hundreds.
He was born into slavery.
He experienced the evils firsthand
of human cruelty.
But what he wrote was that primarily his passion for
what he was working towards came from his faith.
That he understood God's profound
love for humanity
and that ignited in him a passion for justice
and equality in the world.
See, God had transformed his life by his love,
which led him to love God without fear of what
that might lead him into,
but also to work diligently, to change society
that he saw was wrong.
Is God's love that compelling to you?
Let's reflect on that together now.
Just bow your heads with me if you would,
and let's just stop again and abide
and rest in God's love for us.
Said it dozens of times today. We say it every week.
You know even the words, but, but just stop
and listen to what God is saying to your heart right now.
You feel too far gone. You feel cold, you feel numb.
Just stop.
Hear me, hear God's word
in this is love.
Not that we've loved God,
but that God sent his son to be the payment
to cover your sin.
That's love,
to make you a part of his family.
That's love. Rest in that today.
Remember what he's done. Remember who he is.
Rest in that today.
And of course, you and I have not loved him wholeheartedly.
We have not loved our brothers and sisters sacrificially.
We have not loved our enemies radically.
We don't do that perfectly.
Of course, we don't
Let his love compel us towards those things.
Like verse one and two, God, I'm on the altar. Say this.
Maybe pray this to, to him in your own words.
But God, I, I want I, I'm on the altar,
living sacrifice.
God, don't let me crawl back off the altar
that I would die to myself
because you have given me everything.
And, and in your death, Jesus, I have died.
And so I can now live through you, for you, for others
and just ask him to help you how to love him better to
to long to be with Him more.
Ask him for that. He would stir your affection for him.
Maybe it's cold and you're numb. That's okay.
There's more on the table for you.
Run to him. Run to your father.
Ask him how you can love brothers and sisters in the church.
Better ask him how you can love your enemies more radically
than the world would see.
And know that something's happened
in your heart differently.
Something's changed. Ask him to give you the power
by his spirit to do that.
All he's asking of you is just to open your life,
open your hands and say, God, I'm all yours
because of your great love for me.
I believe you are the only way. And so my life is yours.
In a moment, we're gonna sing a song
that's probably new to most of you.
Our students have been singing it for a few months
and it's simple,
but it's a declaration of what we hope
to be able to say 100% in our hearts.
It's true. In part it's true here and there, up and down.
But, but let this be.
Maybe you can't even sing it
yet 'cause it's not true of your heart.
That's okay. Ask God to make it true of you.
Make it true of your heart. All of me, for all of you, God.
So if you're able, let's stand together, sing.